no one person has the same goal or
aspiration and what you get when you
give people money and let them use it is
this real rich human experience where
everyone does something a bit different
hi I'm Anthony Fischer with reason TV
and I'm joined by Paul Niehaus the
president and co-founder of give
directly Paul thanks for joining us my
pleasure
what's give directly give directly is a
relatively new non-profit organization
with a really different concept of how
we can use money to help people overseas
who don't have much we take money from
donors and give it directly to extremely
poor people living in East Africa and
then they get to decide what to do with
it not us what was the impetus behind
starting this yeah you know we got going
when the co-founders and I were in grad
school doing graduate degrees in
economic development and we really
wanted to rethink this basic question of
how can we use money to help people who
don't have much of it and when you put
it that way it's obvious that one thing
you could do is give it to them and let
them use it but typically that's not
what we do right instead what we've
built is almost this benevolent
bureaucracy right of these large
international organizations that
fundamentally are there to make
decisions on behalf of the poor about
what they should get you know should
they get a cow should they get training
should they get a loan so the the money
transfers take place via cell phone what
percentage of the world's poorest
actually have cell phones
well first it's surprisingly high when
we show up in a community and these are
some of the poorest people in the world
so they're living on an average of
around 65 nominal cents a day right so
that means like your morning latte is
probably one week's budget for a typical
recipient many of these people will
still have at least access to a phone
around half of the people that we meet
but you don't actually even need one all
people literally need is a SIM card that
they can plug into someone else's phone
to receive transfers where does the
money come from originally us so when we
first got going it was literally just
friends and family you know we wanted to
be able to give our money this way
because we felt really compelled by the
evidence that it's a very effective way
of giving and just could not find
anybody that would let us give our own
money that way you know it's just very
counter to the way things are typically
done over time what's happened is since
we've launched it publicly the three
years ago is just really rapid growth to
around 20 million in a revenue right now
we're running and I'd say a lot of that
is coming from kind of people in our
generation people who are making money
working in sort of quantitative
industries like finance technology
people who really sort of believe in
quantitative approaches and care about
evidence but I think even an even more
basic level people who want something
that
more authentic and more honest than you
know the traditional way that we've
thought about giving can you estimate
how much more money you think gets
directly to the people through your app
than through traditional charities yeah
that's the question we all want to know
the answer to the reason it's so hard
frankly is because nonprofit accounting
is typically such a mush right so you
can go and get these IRS numbers like
percent overhead percent program
services the problem is they really
don't mean much right so even if you
take the percent going to program
services which what we typically think
about that basically just means how much
money is going to Africa and then all of
that could be going to salaries or
office space or it just doesn't measure
like value created for the recipients so
what we've done is we said something
very simple we're just gonna measure how
efficient we are by what fraction of
every dollar that you give us we put
into the hands of a recipient in Africa
and right now we're running at around 91
cents so I can't compare that but I
think it would be tough to beat the
critics might say that if you don't give
charitable money to a third party then
the recipients might spend it on things
like drugs or alcohol what in your
experience are is how's the money being
spent yeah this is really the core of
the story you know and the reason that
we got going so something important
happened in development around 2000
which is that we started to do
scientific experimental testing right
and it's kind of amazing because we've
been doing development for 50 years and
hadn't really done that very much and
what's great is that when you start
doing science when you sort of put two
things head-to-head and ask what's the
impact you know there are surprises
right so some things that you thought
were gonna work really well turn out not
to and some things that you thought
wouldn't work turn out to work really
well and I think that cash transfer is
just literally giving money to poor
people has turned out to be one of those
really big positive surprises over the
last decade to the point where I think
they're now sort of a stronger more
rigorous scientific evidence base in
favor of cash transfers than just about
any other tool that we have in the
development toolbox so in particular a
lot of those negative stereotypes that
we have people are just gonna get drunk
or they're gonna waste it on gambling
things like that not only has there been
no evidence to suggest that but there's
been if anything evidence I think of the
opposite what kind of data what kind of
evidence do you have what are they
spending the money on yeah so you know
what we see in our data which i think is
great is this real diversity in you know
in some studies we've seen impacts on
health reductions in HIV in others we
seeing these long-term increases in
earnings when you look at our data you
know you'll see there are some people
who buy cows it's about 30% of the
sample there are a lot of people who
invest in upgrading their housing buy
durable assets people's incomes go up by
around 30% for every every dollar that
they receive and then there are crazy
things you know there's one guy who
bought musical instruments and started a
band and tourists so I think you know
part of the story here is that on
average people are doing good things and
their lives are getting better but the
other part of the story is that you know
there really is no on average right
everybody is very different no one
person has the same goal or aspiration
and what you get when you give people
money and let them use it is this real
rich human experience where everyone
does something a bit different is any
part of give directly a reaction to say
bureaucratic waste among you know larger
charities yeah you know I think it's the
way I think about this is you know we do
have this very top-heavy bureaucratic
system there's a lot of overhead in it
and frankly nobody really knows how much
overhead right there are no data to tell
us so it's kind of a guess you know how
much is going to get through and what
it's going to get spent on I I'm
somewhat sympathetic I think that you
know if you looked at the world ten
years ago without the evidence we now
have and without the technology right
that lets us put money electronically
into someone's hands if they have a sim
card you might say you know maybe this
is the best approach the best we can do
but I think those two big trends are the
new evidence and the new technology
really make me step back in question you
know I think we can probably do
something much better how do you get the
word out to people in East Africa how
are they aware of give directly how are
they lining themselves up with the
communication to receive funds we go
door to door so we're primarily a field
organization and that's a bit different
from a lot of other startup nonprofits
recently that are more focused on the
fundraising the marketing side so you
know we control all of our own
operations that means that we have guys
who were going door-to-door in East
Africa they're signing people up for the
program they're capturing data digitally
which were then routing back into our
systems we're auditing we're looking for
fraud and then signing them up for these
mobile payment systems that let them get
money on their phone moving ahead how do
you plan on selling give directly to
America or the first world how are you
going to convince people that this is
the future giving people cash for them
to spend it on their on whatever they
see fit yeah we're you know I'm really
excited about this and I think I'd be
perfectly honest that over the first few
years we've really just focused on kind
of reaching out communicating to people
like us people
pretty quantitative if you like to lead
research papers who care about numbers
so it's been great to connect with that
community I think we have a wonderful
support base but um you know we also
think there's a much more human side to
this that we do want people to be able
to experience so longer-term you know
with all the data that we have in our in
our databases you know we have people's
photographs we have their stories we
know what their aspirations are their
goals their challenges and we know when
something goes wrong so we know if
someone has to pay a bribe or if there's
a prod their house burns down if there's
a bad outcome and we really want people
to get that unfiltered view right I
think that the way the poor are
presented to us today through nonprofit
marketing is this very stylized spun
version where we pick a few success
stories and they say that's the way it
is we'd like you to be able to see for
the specific people that I gave my money
to here's what actually happened and
there will be successes and failures and
things that you never would have
expected and I think it's an exciting
adventure has there been any pushback on
the ground in East Africa or from other
charitable organizations that feel like
your model doesn't work or that you're
chiseling a no matter territory you know
it's a funny thing you know because of
all this evidence cash transfers are now
widely accepted by governments by
institutions by the kind of eight
agencies of the world less so by the
typical American on the street it's
still a bit of a new idea so we've heard
criticism we've had people tell us you
guys must be smoking crack you know
anything you can imagine but I think
those are the good conversations to have
right it's great to get out and talk
about what are our preconceptions and
what are the data actually say and and I
relish it thanks so much for talking to
us Paul Niehaus the president of give
directly for Reason TV I'm Anthony
Fischer
you